season 15 of America's Got Talent next
week Tuesday at 8:00 Eastern on NBC and
the man who is hosting that great
program from Brooklyn nine-nine a man
who has done a ton with his career after
leaving the National Football League and
is an inspiration to so many Terry Crews
back here on the program how are you
Terry I'm doing good rich how you doing
man better for talking to you everybody
finding your world your life your family
knocking on wall now we're doing good
man we're doing good I'll be honest with
you though that means all this
quarantine stuff it sucks it definitely
sucks you know but I'm looking at it
glass half-full
we're alive we're healthy and we are
ready to go brother I look forward to
that and obviously seeing America's Got
Talent next week next Tuesday a lot of
fans are looking forward to that Mille
we'll talk about that in a second is
there any any time during this
quarantine that you flipped the
television on and have seen an old game
of yours that you were playing and have
you seen oh yeah does that happen at all
Terry I mean that's the internet though
the internet always said me old clips
and all that stuff but on TV it doesn't
get played that often I was caught up in
the whole laugh dance thing man holy cow
every weekend I was glued to the TV
brother what did what you learn from
that one you know what I learned man is
you know I
and this is the I had already learned
this stuff I mean when I play an NFL but
one thing I learned is that you know the
what what is successful in sports it's
not necessarily successful in life you
know what I mean like people think that
there's a sports attitude yeah that's
the way to do it and all of a sudden
you'll be more successful in life but a
lot of times this stuff leads to very
things that I had to get rid of you know
what I mean like the whole competition
aspect the grudges the fights the whole
thing I'm like me you know I'm glad I'm
out of that to be honest with it it just
reminded me of a lot of really pettiness
that I had to really get out of my life
very very petty petty show that's
fascinating
by the way with you now working in
Hollywood saying that there's a scene
more petty than that that is a headline
Hollywood in sports but again people
think remember you can understand people
think that all successful actor oh my
god he must be a successful person but
let me tell you i we got 50 million
examples of how that does not work right
yeah and so it's the same way and my
thing is is that really really it's all
about how you finish you know I mean a
lot of people put a lot of play on how
you start but to me it's always been
like but to be my right now at 52 years
old I wouldn't go back to 21 or anything
I didn't know anything but at the time
hey he's on his way to NFL he's doing
all this great stuff but it's really how
you finish brother that's really what
that makes the difference well I mean
you're touching on a few things I want
to I want to pull on some of these
strands with you Terry so when you say
pettiness when you were playing and that
you had to get rid of it are you saying
that this this stuff that you thought
you needed to do in order to succeed and
then you realized as you were getting
out of sports that that you didn't I'm
wondering what what exactly are you
referring to when you say I am referring
to I had you know there are certain
think duels that you you get you feel
like you have to be a certain person in
order to make it you know I remember
getting this is strange I yeah I
remember getting into fights on the bus
in the NFL you know what I mean and
people were you know we would get mad at
each other and the whole deal and you
carry those grudges you know what I mean
even for years even after it's gone and
then you look back and you realize an
obvious be honest the person that I was
fighting on that bus is gone he's dead
and you realize wait a minute man you
know there's things that are bigger than
this you know cuz that game at one time
with the biggest thing ever but
everybody's on to the new stuff you know
what I mean if you still hold an honor
to stuff it can really really wreck you
you know and that's the example that
that that's one example of the pettiness
that you can carry that you realize man
I'm not a man when somebody who's not
even here anymore you know what I mean
so you gotta just let it go
well I mean you Jordan
he's Terry Crews here in the richezza
show are you talking about the last ants
it seems to me that you know when he
would hold on to he's still holding on
to stuff I mean is you know in a man in
his late 50s with all the trophies in
the case and he's won the no in the way
that we are viewing his style and the
way he would deal with his teammates or
or talk to them or be with them that
that that that we we lionize it because
he has six trophies right I love you got
a no I love Michael Jordan sir what he
is and I love everything about him but
then when you look at you know the thing
between him and Isaiah or him in a horse
grant you just wish they all go out and
you said you know that's right I have a
lemonade you know I mean relax it's like
dude you guys have made it you guys have
went in and any bit of I'm hopefully I'm
hoping that you know behind the scenes
that they were able to get together but
to hear that him and Isaiah have
something at each other cuz I grew up in
Michigan but Isaiah Thomas you know what
I mean and I loved Isaiah at the same
time and I love Jordan and to see that
you know they're not getting along
hopefully in the in the show it looked
like they didn't get along and you just
want people to be at peace with each
other because you got a realize life is
short man it's really really short so
are you saying Terry that that's not
lemonade and that tumbler next to Jordan
during the last time could be some form
of aid I don't know but we can all get
caught into that rich listen I've been
in there I have I'm guilty I'm not
sitting here saying Jordan is it there
are things that I that my wife has
called me on she's like do you need to
let that go
that was a law that was back when you
were playing and all this stuff and I'm
like you're right you know I mean these
are things that creep back up and if you
don't really do the the due diligence
that looking at they're examining your
own thinking you can be trapped by some
of that stuff man it doesn't matter how
much money you make or how successful
you are so what was it like and why'd
you do it go to NFL Europe why'd you go
to the
fire Terry again I just love your
journey we now know you obviously is a
very successful actor television host
you are you are you are - it now here in
this town but you were also a member of
the Rhine fire I don't think anybody
else on television can say something
like that let me tell you I had been cut
by the San Diego Chargers the year
before and what was crazy is that I was
told once a week by my coach that they
were gonna bring me back and they never
did and I mean all 16 weeks at NFL
season yes I understand the next year
the charges went all the way to Super
Bowl right and they still kept telling
me we're gonna bring you back we're
gonna bring you back and I was crushed
man I was waiting paying my own rent
trying to stay in town for this team
that I thought was gonna bring me back
and they never did and I thought going
to the Rhine fire was my only way back
into the NFL that was my thing and it
turned out it was I was one of only
seven players in the whole NFL Europe to
make it back into the lead in that year
who else was playing with you in an NFL
Europe down there you know Torretta
was playing oh my god the big
quarterback that just just retired from
from the league from Indianapolis I'm
blanking out right now no Andrew Luck
Andrew Luck with a kid that's what he is
Oliver's father ran the league and so
Andrew was running around on the
sideline just a little kid man I'll say
Andrew told me that ball you know and
now you know he's now retired and the
whole thing that just shows you how old
I am but did you pick up German did you
did you talk to him not at all not at
all I got a little bit Archie didn't
take German in Western Michigan you
didn't do that not at all thing I mean
you know they didn't really want us over
there either it was not a very good
thing I mean we we they're not used to
they didn't use to they were used to
American football it was kind of wild
and I thought it was going to be better
than it was and I made it back got
picked up by the Redskins
I was so happy to be back so who'd
what's the and last football question
for them we'll turn to your your
America's Got Talent
best play you Terry Crews ever made in
the hi were knocked out on Monday Night
Football that I knocked myself out okay
Clarence Bird in and this was so crazy
he was the smallest man in the NFL right
kickoff returner and I was gonna kick
off and I was on the charges we play at
Indianapolis Colts and I come down on a
kickoff and bow I knock this guy I know
I busted his chin and then I fall out
and I'm gone I'm telling you getting
knocked out was the most peaceful
feeling I ever felt in my entire life I
was back in the womb rich I'm trying to
tell you man I didn't have no up or down
or no pain right you knew that's why you
get knocked out cuz your body's like
okay we quit and uh but holy cow what a
headache I had afterwards but it was a
hit man I got hit it a week and yeah
give you t-shirts for all that stuff you
know I mean was it crazy back in the day
so that's when I asked you your best
play you made in the NFL you're saying
it was when you got knocked out on
Monday night I mean everybody else but I
had to look at that on a replay because
I did not remember it happening okay I
just learned that it when they played it
back right back
so maybe again you were in quarantine
we'll flip on see that see that game
with Terry Crews here on the Rich Eisen
show all right let's talk America's Got
Talent
it looks like you're having a blast
doing this Terry I love it I love it I
tell my wife keeps telling me not to say
this anymore but I gonna continue say
because I would host this show for free
it's satisfying
most amazed you are giving away dreams
dude and you gotta understand why I say
that is because I was I actually hosted
my high school talent show when I was in
high school my destiny you know I mean I
feel like I'm walking into something I
was always being prepared for and didn't
know it and my god dude it's just
gigantic it's the world's biggest talent
show
it's so much fun and dude season 15 this
is our best ever because we had to go
through this whole Kovac thing like you
won't believe this
yeah tell me how what what that was like
him what what to expect here you know
we've been more we've been super
successful so the crowds are always
there we have a full packed audience
then all of a sudden you know this is
back when Koba it was just a rumor right
and know what was going on right and all
of a sudden it was like a pool being
drained I mean the audience got more and
more Sparsit and we were and then Heidi
got sick and she quarantined herself
just to protect everyone else cuz she
thought oh my god is going around right
so we had three judges and finally went
down to no audience rich it was crazy it
was like what is happening does it was
almost like I don't know what to say it
looks like the are you know the
apocalypse could was happening you know
what I mean and you're gonna see this
happen literally episode by episode and
it's gonna be crazy all these comedians
and I've had a corm with no audience hey
I mean I think for the return of
Sportster we're all gonna have to get
used to that right yeah Sports is the
best way I could pretty much kind of
like it similar it just because you
can't have an audience anymore but this
is the deal I think will be more
successful simply because you have the
people craving it you know what I mean
like what can I say I think you know
when I look at a chi chi just like I
look at the NFL or an NBA when you play
something on TV and it doesn't really
matter if you were there or not you're
there in spirit
you know what I'm saying so it's gonna
be gigantic with all these people at
home yeah and Sofia Vergara added to the
crew and the cast this year or you know
her husband Joe Manganiello if you did
get to meet him before everything shut
down I'm sure he might have been talking
your ear off about football - man I've
known Joe for years I actually did a
movie with three years ago called soul
playing with a little guy that's going
up and so he became the most literally
one of the most famous people on earth
true since then and it's Wow to watch
people grow
and know that life keeps going and like
I said it's truly how you finish brother
absolutely hey Terry always loved our
chats always oh really the marriage
right back at you right back at you
Congrats as always on your success and
we'll be we'll be checking out America's
Got Talent season 15 premiering next
week on NBC Tuesday at 8:00 eastern time
we'll check it out wow you got it thank
you guys thank you
right back at you that's Terry Crews act
Terry Crews on Twitter right here on the
Rich Eisen shown also Brooklyn nine-nine
a great funny television show with our
buddy Joel 'truly oh hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here